this week in show history one year ago
this week terrorists attacked the office
a French satirical magazine Charlie
Hebdo leaving 12 people dead we talked
in reaction to that Louis a year ago
about whether France would or would not
go in the direction of draconian
surveillance bills they did pass new
surveillance measures we also since the
Charlie Hebdo attacks saw another large
horrible attack in Paris late in 2015 I
actually have friends now uh I mean I
kits it's two people I can think of who
will not travel to France because of the
Islamic state they believe it has become
so dangerous in France that they would
not go there I for that that to me I
understand being scared based on what's
happened but I would absolutely go to
France at this time Lewis the odds of
being victim of a terrorist attack in
France right now in spite of the Charlie
Hebdo and the more recent of massacre
are still incredibly low yeah it's not
something I I would worry about uh I
don't have any plans to go to France you
know that's it's fine but I I think you
can travel there I don't you have to
worry and but i do think France has to
worry because France has become a huge
target and you know I just say I I feel
bad but you know they they have handled
this very well but you know i'd imagine
it's on their minds way more than the
minds of people who might want to travel
there but so you would you think they'd
handle it well in terms of the new
surveillance bills that they passed you
think that those those are logical well
uh that i think just kinda is expected
comes with the territory but as far as
continuing to let refugees in and
allowing more refugees in i mean they
haven't been completely paralyzed by
fear when I was in France but most
recently which was last year uh I guess
over this this past summer I went by a
synagogue which was being rebuilt and
you know renovated etcetera and there
were about ten members of the French
military with automatic weapons outside
and I wanted to take a picture not of
synagogue but acts
they wanted to take a picture of the
fact that there was this armed military
presence right outside of the synagogue
and I took out my phone and I sort of
acted like I was taking a picture of the
synagogue and immediately two of these
armed guys came right over and told me
I'm not allowed to take pictures of the
synagogue and it sort of was it
illuminated the sort of state that that
there are some aspects of society in
right now although broadly speaking
filled with tourists people going
absolutely all over the place we stayed
in a neighborhood that was not like a
touristy neighborhood but more
equivalent to like a Brooklyn in New
York City and all all felt absolutely
fine but more more than one person I
know said you know I'm scared of going
to France right now well I've heard
people say that they were considering
not going out on New Year's in New York
City because of the same thing and says
you know uh it's it's too bad but I
understand why people think that way you
know I thought that way I thought to
myself maybe I should just avoid this
big crowd or this parade or something
like that but like where for example
parade where did you think maybe I
should avoid it I don't know something
that might might happen here in in in
Boston you know just in general I think
do I want to be in these areas uh I will
it ultimately prevent me from doing that
I don't think so but it's still in the
back of my mind